a startup especially as a founder is a
calling and if you're not called to that
if you can't get that out of your head
you're not passionately engaged waking
up at 3:00 in the morning making notes
if it's not the first thing you're
thinking about in the shower and you
know convincing your family that this is
the thing that you need to dedicate your
life to don't even think about doing it
because the amounts of success in a
start-up are infinitesimally low
this has to be passion driven not career
driven or salary driven and so that's
the first thing I remind the students
who either want to be part of a founding
team or an early employee this is not a
job
entrepreneurs are closer to artists than
any other career we make the mistake and
teaching entrepreneurship in thinking
that it's akin to a business school
curriculum or an engineering curriculum
entrepreneurship it just happens to sit
in those schools but truly the
curriculum that it's closest to is art
school not because while we teach you
know art appreciation we teach our
theory all right art is really
experiential and it's passion driven
it's not that you're gonna do one code
or two I mean you're gonna be looking at
a blank canvas then the next day there's
gonna be starry night if we're lucky